welcome back to drew's news ross
as a true connoisseur of reality
television thank you so much thank you i
need your take on this oh my gosh okay
okay so hello giggles talk to experts to
break down exactly why people are on the
reality tv feeder and they had different
takes some said it's because they were
so busy and so disconnected from people
in their real lives they just wanted to
hang out with a bunch of people for a
sense of connection
other experts said more about the pure
fun of living vicariously through other
people going through their love affairs
and you know all sorts of life stuff and
the safety and comfort from their own
sweatpants it sounds like a risk reward
if you ask me sure um now what is your
favorite reality television show i've
talked about here i'll talk about it
anywhere but i could teach a phd course
in 90 day fiance thank you so much
do you have anybody else yes
welly and i we get home and we know we
make a little dinner and we watch it and
we we have opinions about i mean when
you watch reality tv shows you fall in
love with the people you invest in the
people and that's what i do i actually
care about their happiness and
i know i know i know oh no no i mean to
acknowledge the countless hours that
you've spent watching 90 day fiance i
wanted to give you a little surprise two
surprises actually it's a package deal
please welcome to the desk 90 day fiance
stars darcy and stacy
get over here
[Applause]
you know how much i love you now which
one's who's who who's who stays who's
darcy i always have a problem darcy
darcy stacy ross and drew hi
okay
i know
so much about you i can't i cannot
believe this is happening you guys kept
this a surprise for me but uh what did i
have spent so much time with you and i
hope that's not creepy no not at all at
all oh wow
we've watched you fall in and out of
love on 90 day and then we you guys got
your own spin-off show and we have seen
love blossom and love
wilt uh where are we now in terms of our
love story how are we doing
well for me i have some new breaking
news i'm no longer with georgie oh yeah
got re-engaged in the summer but it just
didn't work out and i felt like i needed
to stand in my power and
just love me more and you know
i feel much happier i feel free yeah
good i'm glad you're taking the right
ones out there somewhere yeah yes
are you ready
yeah you know single ready to mingle hey
you hear that audience single ready to
mingle
and what about you what's going on with
your loved ones still married with
florian yeah seven years together and
obviously we met way before any tv show
and
you know
we're good can i tell you let me i don't
know if you can feel the energy i'm just
looking at you i'm so happy i've spent
so many hours in bed with you and i've
never
the first time i've ever said that to
two women
but i really i just have to say you know
you share your life you know and so just
thank you for opening your life because
i have been invested for a very very
long time thank you
and thank you for surprising me
also
you guys um have a new show
that premieres tonight can we talk about
that really quickly absolutely okay so
darcy and stacy tell all there's a
special and we actually have a clip
right oh my god
do you think georgie's gonna show up
nurse
georgie's not gonna come today so you
know i'm angry
[Music]
hey babe i don't want to be there
with other people
i don't like any man talking to my
daughters like that any man
oh my god
how do you guys feel about this new show
it's
really going to tell a lot and show a
lot and you know stacy and i always like
come from an authentic place and you'll
see a lot of truths come out and the
fact that you know my excellent show was
just another reason why i just knew my
gut like once it left
my head like my body followed i just you
know hit my limit and i had to say
goodbye
but um
it was a great experience i feel like it
was healing it was very healing it is it
is but i'm just thinking about what you
need on the next season i think it's a
sassy gay friend that you can go to
happy hour with every episode and just
throwing it out there that if
you need anybody hey put us on speed
though
well thank you darcy and stacy silva and
the darcy and stacy tell all special
airs tonight on tlc and we're so honored
to be talking about it and thank you so
much you really have brought so much joy
to rossi's life
[Applause]
thank you for surprising
[Music]